ALAQUA COX [in sign language]
Hey everyone! I'm Alaqua Cox,
and I play Maya Lopez in
the new series Hawkeye on Disney+!
TRINH TRAN
We went worldwide to look for
our Maya Lopez, and we really wanted to
stay true to the characters in the comics.
ALAQUA COX [in sign language]
I never dreamt of being an actor.
IVAN
Maybe I rip out your throat.
Or, maybe, she will.
ALAQUA COX [in sign language]
A tweet said "female, Native, athletic, smart"...
Everyone texted me, "This is you!"
The rest of it's history.
BERTIE
She's brand new to this whole thing.
Something that happens with some actors,
that when they step in front of the camera
there's this kind of, like, collective
inhale of breath, and everyone's like...
[Gasping]
She's just got
this star quality to her.
JEREMY RENNER
Alaqua is amazing.
She's really just wide-open emotionally,
and was able to contribute a lot.
She's a natural.
ALAQUA COX [in sign language]
Honestly, I was very nervous.
I didn't know what to do,
because this whole world of acting...
Everything was new to me.
BERT
She's an amazing character to have set up,
and with a new actress like
Alaqua is, that's been such a gift for us.
ALAQUA COX [in sign language]
I feel very proud, and I'm excited to show
everyone that for people
with disabilities, anything is possible.